[Music]
all right
so what are we looking at what new hell
have we sunk to now
here in the united states if they ask
you how you are you just have to say
that you're fine and you're not really
fine but you just can't get into it
because they would never understand well
it's a kentucky police patrol car with a
blue lives matter
thin blue line punisher skull on the
hood
um there's a lot to unpack here
but let's stick to tradition and begin
by examining the skull
the skull is the symbol of the punisher
the marvel comics vigilante anti-hero
the punisher's real name is frank
castilloni but he changed it to frank
castle i guess because he's ashamed of
his sicilian heritage
disappointing frank castle is an
ex-marine whose wife and kids are
murdered by the mob leaving him an empty
husk of a man whose only consolation is
his obsession with revenge nia
there's been a lot of tv and movie
adaptations of the punisher and his
research for this video i did watch all
of them
and my conclusion is that the best one
is the 1989 version where dolph lundgren
dyes his hair black to pass his sicilian
and runs around naked and sweaty in the
sewers worshiping the god of vengeance
at a shrine of trash
you know just like the police do
number 60. hi i'm natalie creator of
catra points
and no i'm not a cat girl i'm a cat
woman i'm sorry you're intimidated by
that
look i'm tired of only being valued for
my petite
heterosexual body i'd like to be
recognized for my worth as a mother
as a wife and
as a woman with values just kidding i'm
trash
let's talk about justice oolu justice is
when i get
lots of headphones the punisher's main
quest is to kill all the mobsters who
murdered his family
but once he gets revenge he can't stop
killing because it's the only thing that
gives
meaning to his shitty life so he wages a
one-man war on organized crime but no
matter how many bad guys he kills it's
never
enough because new criminals just come
along and take the place of the old ones
it's like a cycle where violent city
gets
violence and nothing ever really changes
it's almost
like this comic book is trying to tell
us something about the nature of crime
and punishment
but you know what let's not overthink
this sure just slap a giant skull on the
car
great perfect are we the baddies look
maybe you're assuming i'm one of these
lib tarted antifa sympathizing
big government anarchists who sits
behind my iphone with my latte
criticizing the police even though i
could never do a job one-tenth as
difficult as theirs
and to that i say how dare you assume
things that are entirely correct
this is excuse me a damn fine cup of
coffee there's just nothing better than
waking up in the morning
and having the first dose of the
chemical you're addicted to they tried
to make me go to rehab i said
[Music]
you seem like a reasonable person a
person of science a
seasoned vendor at the free marketplace
of ideas gorge
and as a reasonable person i'm sure you
wouldn't dismiss my argument just
because
i happen to enjoy head paths as socrates
once said
two plus two is four is equally true
whether uttered by a philosopher king or
a peasant nave
or a neko mimi kawai daves
this problematic cringe culture is dead
and we have killed it this is beyond
cringe
this is cursed children cursed so
actually socrates didn't say this quote
i just made it up but
that just proves the point i'm making so
maybe you should hear me out
yeah i'm making this video at a time
when hundreds of videos of police
brutality are being shared on social
media
spurring on a movement to abolish police
and prisons and at the same time
there's a growing culture of online
vigilantism where justice is taken into
the hands of twitter mobs demanding
accountability and consequences for bad
behavior
all of this raises a lot of questions
questions like
what should the consequences be for bad
behavior who should impose these
consequences
and under what circumstances and for
what purpose
if we were to abolish police in prisons
what would take their place
oh my god these contacts i'm literally
doing a whole video with [ __ ]
sideways cat eyes ridiculous
why don't we start with the basics and
ask ourselves what is justice socrates
it's a question philosophers have
pondered for thousands of years
with no conclusive answers
i think i can probably figure this out
in a youtube video because the
philosophers were dummies
and i am very smart rah-rah rasputin
one revenge the punisher represents a
particular idea about what justice is
symbolized by the skull he wears on his
t-shirt so that bad guys know
they're about to get punished the
punisher's view is that justice means
harming people who harm people
an eye for an eye this is called
retributive justice
the idea that people who commit crimes
deserve punishment in proportion to
their crime
it's a very emotionally powerful idea of
what justice is
because it's rooted in our instinct to
strike back at someone who's harmed us
social animals like humans and
chimpanzees often practice revenge
probably because it serves an
evolutionary function if another monkey
in your monkey troop steals your bananas
and you don't get revenge then other
monkeys will learn that you're a doormat
monkey
but if you get revenge on the thief
monkey by
i don't know letting her boyfriend pick
parasites out of your fur
then that sends a message to the other
monkeys that it is not
profitable to mess with you so our
little monkey brains
have evolved a taste for vengeance and
even in cases where it doesn't actually
benefit us
our desire for retribution is strong and
our little monkey brains
reward us with a pleasant feeling of
catharsis
when justice of this kind is served so
of course
there's a lot of content out there
devoted to scratching this
itch for example there's a subreddit
called r slash justice served with one
and a half million subscribers
i first found justice search when the
popular feed showed me this post of two
teenage thieves
stripped naked humiliated and
photographed as
punishment and all this celebrated under
the heading police justice
in fact before the murder of george
floyd by police
the description of the community was now
with 20
more police brutality um fun fact
this ain't it chief period full stop
that's the tweet of course i subscribe
to justice served right away thinking
someone should be keeping an eye on
these people here's a typical justice
surge post
woman sets p-e-d-o husband on
fire after catching him r-a-p-e
seven-year-old daughter titled this man
got what he deserved
instant regret predator exposed to be
honest when i wrote this part of the
script i forgot i was going to be
wearing carriers i'm really out here
trying to have a conversation about
immolating sex offenders while
dressed like a aging bargain bin
bell delphine impersonator well
dress for the job you want i mean humsta
amongst us wouldn't set their husband on
fire under those circumstances right
let's look at the comments on that post
though let's read the room
she's a hero in my opinion should have
had it live on television
give her a medal give her two medals so
most people are in favor of setting
predators ablaze
but you know there's always a couple
buzz kills in there whining as usual
about
oh maybe we shouldn't be cheering on
burning people alive with no due process
and no evidence
lots of men like to [ __ ] my wife because
i'm too busy crying about due process
but those people get shouted down pretty
fast
they get called pedo simps pedo
so justice served is a community for
people to gather together
and bond over our shared love of
extrajudicial violence
but of course there's always someone who
takes it a little too far
on this video of a thief being kicked in
the head until his face is a bloody pulp
one commenter says that's a justice
boner for me
i dream of the day i catch the thieves
that stole from me
and kicked the life out of them criminal
fail prank gone wrong so
when the righteous zeal for justice
becomes the cloak of bloodlust
that is off-putting to some people as
one disgruntled former justice service
subscriber put it
i wanted to see stories and videos of
[ __ ] getting their comeuppance
instead i got bombarded with an angry
toxic moral absolutism everything is
black and white with them
if you don't support mutilating someone
beyond repair
then you must support giving them a slap
on the wrist and letting them [ __ ] your
wife
unsubscribed but even this liberal
cuckold still wanted to watch
videos of [ __ ] getting their
comeuppance i think pretty much everyone
is
capable of enjoying some version of this
type of content
there's a lot of sub genres you've got
justice porn
play stupid games win stupid prizes
instant karma
bad parking revenge predator poaching
serial killer sentenced to death and the
whole train clapped
instant justice was served karma fails
stupid people getting what they deserved
karma
a lot of this content has kind of a
right-wing feel to it
unmarked police justice criminal gets
shot after fighting cop
home invader takes shotgun blast to the
balls arizona just arizona
what more is there to say arizona
justice served
punished it reminds me of nra people who
spend 10 hours a day fantasizing about
how they're gonna kill home intruders
with the gun they keep in the bathroom
but i don't think this longing for
retribution is distinctively right-wing
left-wing people have the exact same
emotional response
they just have it in different
situations think about the jubilation on
twitter
when they get a racist care and fired
remember that ugly hug
lisa who harassed a black man in front
of an apartment building
karma and she got her husband fired
dumb [ __ ] really should have minded her
business love to see it
she will probably end up with community
service
and a fine but i would love to see her
in jail
for at least six months firing them was
not enough
life in prison
life in prison an example i personally
enjoy is that video of daniel holtzclaw
the cop who abused his power to sexually
assault a series of black women
crying in court as he's sentenced to
serve 263 years in prison
[Music]
he just cannot believe that he's
actually facing consequences for this
and of course there's the much savered
the vigilante punching of
nazi richard spencer let's watch it now
please try not to enjoy this remember
this is purely for
educational monetizable purposes
it's uh pepe has become kind of a symbol
that was informative but let's be honest
the reason that video was so popular
is people just enjoyed watching an nazi
get what he deserves justice
served punished smashing very happy they
found
remember to smash subscribe so this
punitive
retributive impulse no matter how
righteous it feels
is still basically a situational form
of sadism of shot and freuda the
satisfaction of justice served
is the pleasure we take in inflicting or
witnessing
the suffering of someone who deserves it
now the phrase deserves it is doing a
lot of work here
the correct use of that phrase is the
difference between a morally
well-adjusted person
and someone who's hiding bodies in the
crawl space it puts the lotion on its
skin yeah but people generally agree
that those who harm others deserve to be
harmed themselves
it's why we love stories about revenge
stories like
mean girls the crow old boy
titus andronicus and matilda much too
good for children
revenge is such a popular plotline
because it's easy for people to identify
with a revenge seeking protagonist
and it's just the easiest way to hype
people up about spectacles of violence
this technique was used in one of the
first books ever the odyssey by homer
i stole this copy from my high school
and i stole this copy from my college
i still just read the spark notes well
let's read it now see
i knew this would be useful someday
god he's such a [ __ ] boy what does
athena see in this man
it must be really hot okay i'm ready for
my book report
so the hero of the story is odysseus and
the whole book is him
trying to get home to the island of
ithaca after um
okay so in the prequel odysseus shitty
friend menelaus throws a tantrum
after his wife leaves him to run off
with a turkish guy she was actually
attracted to how dare she
so menelaus dragged an entire nation to
war
instead of doing what any normal man
would do and blowing off some steam at
femboy symposium
anyway when odysseus finally gets back
to ithaca he finds that his house is
full of men
who are eating his food and drinking his
wine
and trying to marry his wife so odysseus
and this is the hero of our story here
he murders all of his wife's suitors as
payback
and then he rounds up all the slave
women who slept with the suitors and he
has them all hanged
and this one suitor valentius odysseus
ties him up and cuts off his ears and
nose and feet
and then rips off his genitals to feed
to the dogs
in reading this i guess i find myself
asking uh
was this really necessary like as a test
reader my feedback for homer is
maybe workshop this i mean super
unlikable protagonist
really kind of kills it for me i guess
it's a male protagonist and you can get
away with making them unlikable because
men love hearing about [ __ ] that's
why they watch my channel
but the crazy thing is i don't think
odysseus is supposed to be an [ __ ]
the text seems to approve of what he
does to the suitors
and to his uh his slaves
yikes disappointing casual reminder
that odysseus kills his slaves it isn't
a good look
wow this blew up i don't have a
soundcloud give me money oh my god this
contact
is fully horizontal this is the last
time we're doing cat eye contacts
[ __ ] this it just seems disproportionate
you know like it's not even eye for an
eye because the suitors didn't kill
anyone they were basically just
rude to odysseus but i guess you have to
understand this kind of thing in
cultural context
they came into his home and they
disrespected his wife and
probably she was into it but whatever
will play along so that was an affront
to odysseus's honor
and on the island of ithaca in the year
1000 to bc or whatever
honor was everything because this was a
pre-legal society
no laws no courts no cops schools out
[ __ ] 12. so honor
is a code of conduct enforced by
reputation and that's what kept people
from stealing and lying and murdering
each other
though it was also often the thing
causing them to murder each other
because back then honor was the only
thing protecting people from being taken
advantage of
if you're an ancient mycenean king then
someone invites themself into your house
and drinks your wine and seduces your
wife
well you can't let them get away with
that because then people will walk all
over you
so you need to get revenge to protect
your honor to maintain your reputation
as a person who is not to be messed with
it's also the point of hard masculinity
in honor cultures
heart masculinity is a defensive posture
an intimidating posture it showcases
strength
and hides vulnerability we call it toxic
masculinity now
because in our society it's destructive
and dysfunctional we've moved beyond the
need for this which is why it's possible
for me to exist if society collapses and
we go back to achilles and odysseus
i'm in danger i'm much too delicate for
this mycenaean
savagery back at homer's time might be
well
i'd be a slave at femme boy symposium
extremely sad gay sounds
neo but for people in situations where
appealing to community or state law
enforcement is not an
option such as kings of ancient
mediterranean islands or
gangsters who need to resolve conflicts
outside of the law
or wild west cowboys hard masculinity
has a function
it's a warning signal like a skull
t-shirt are the stripes on a poisonous
snake
and the poison is vengeance justice
served
so revenge is arguably the most basic
form of retributive justice
the philosopher francis bacon defined
revenge as a wild
justice according to the first paragraph
of the wikipedia article about revenge
research i am very smart nia but in most
modern legal systems
revenge is frowned upon and for pretty
good reasons
an eye for an eye will make the whole
world blind didn't you know that
if someone harms you and you get revenge
by killing him
then his family is gonna try to get
revenge by killing you
it's a cycle a cycle of smashing at the
end of the odyssey
the families of the suitors odysseus
killed band together
and plot to get revenge by killing
odysseus and literally the last thing
that happens in the odyssey is that the
goddess athena who has an inexplicable
lady boner for odysseus
steps in and saves him by just
making the families forget that odysseus
killed their children
so only divine intervention in amnesia
stops the cycle of violence
but in reality that doesn't happen very
much so these cycles can last for
decades or even
centuries in albania there's an ancient
code called the canon
which requires a family to commit murder
in order to preserve their honor when
another family offends against them
life for life blood for blood this
historically led to blood feuds between
families that could last for generations
and in fact it still sometimes happens
in parts of northern albania
there's documentaries on youtube about
families who are trapped at home
possibly for the rest of their lives
because there's a vendetta against them
and if they leave the house
they'll be murdered historically blood
feuds led to a high mortality rate for
young men
which may have contributed to the
tradition of what are called albanian
sworn virgins
these are assigned female at birth
people who would take a vow of chastity
in exchange for getting to live as men
there's still some of them around and in
a very patriarchal society they're
socially recognized as
men allowed to wear men's clothes use a
male name u act as head of a household
inherit family wealth and generally have
the rights and privileges of a man
extremely happy trans sounds ubu i bring
this up just because i think it shows
how devastating the blood feuds must
have been
because only desperation would lead a
european country hundreds of years ago
to support trans rights
no one wants that so you know it was a
last resort um
sworn virgins weren't transgender most
were compelled yeah i know that sweaty
it was just a joke okay calm down
revenge cycles also happen on a larger
scale
between communities nations ethnicities
religions i'm worried if i give a real
example i'll be canceled for seeming
neutral about a conflict where i'm
supposed to take a side
so in the interest of cowardice let's
say
that the cat girls bombed the dog girls
and then the dog girls bombed the cat
girls and that cycle repeats for a few
decades
and by that point both nations have such
a long and bitter list of grievances
against each other that reconciliation
is close to impossible
extremely angry gay sounds
so a revenge based code of honor is not
really an ideal justice system
it's bloody it's chaotic and it produces
these endless
cycles of violence so at some point in
the growth of a civilization
something has to be done to control the
chaos caused by vengeance
and the most popular way to do that is
to create a state legal system
two retribution the extremely heck and
cute and valid german sociologist
max weber defined the state as the
organization with a monopoly on the
legitimate use of violence
in an honor society with no rule of law
anyone is allowed to kill someone as
long as they do so in accordance with
the code of honor but once you have
the state usually only the government is
allowed to kill people
in ancient babylon there was a king
called hammurabi who enacted one of the
first
law codes in the world around 1750 bc
an era that scholars refer to as history
times
the code of hammurabi looked like this
the laws were
crudely scratched into this stone using
some
primitive attempt at writing i mean it
was like a thousand years ago so
i'm sure they were doing their best it's
very good sweetie
i'll hang it up on the refrigerator for
you are they supporting this replica to
be bigger
sort of a spinal tap stonehenge
situation
the actual hammurabi steelies were about
seven feet tall and they were publicly
placed in the city so that everyone knew
what the laws were
even though most people were illiterate
but hey they tried sort of let's read
some of hammurabi's laws
that's content right cat girl reacts to
the code of hammurabi
nia's queen
we don't deserve rights so there's 282
laws and they're all in if then
form so if you do x then the punishment
is why
law 22 if anyone is committing a robbery
and is caught then he shall be put to
death
that's extremely valid if a son of a
paramore or prostitute say to his
adoptive father or mother
you are not my father or my mother his
tongue shall be cut off
at least they're standing up for
adoptive parents if a man put out the
eye of another man
his eye shall be put out now we're
getting into some of the classics
if he breaks another man's bone his bone
shall be broken
if a freed man strike the body of
another freed man
he shall pay 10 shekels and money but if
the slave of a freed man strike the body
of a freed man
his ear shall be cut off oh so there's
different punishments for different
classes
so it's like our legal system except
honest if a builder built a house for
someone and does not construct it
properly
in the house which he will fall in and
kill its owner
then that builder shall be put to death
if it killed the son of the owner
the son of that builder shall be put to
death love that okay
so by modern standards the code of
hammurabi
does not pass the vibe check the
vibrations are very negative it's a lot
of cutting people's hands off and
burning them alive
just a major vibe killer all around but
you have to credit hammurabi's code
for resolving the problem of honor
driven revenge cycles
you know if you live in babylon and
someone harms you instead of retaliating
against their family and
potentially starting a generations long
blood feud
you take your grievance to the elders of
the city who reach a verdict and impose
a sentence just as served so the
involvement of a neutral third party is
one major difference
between vigilante revenge and a state
legal system of retributive justice
let's list all the differences revenge
is personal in the sense that
it's the victim who does the avenging
it's often emotional
an act of passion it can be
disproportionate as an odysseus killing
the suitors for
squatting in his palace and it's
sadistic it's satisfying to the avenger
revenge is sweet on the other hand a
legal system of retributive justice
is impersonal in the sense that the
punishment is imposed by a third party
the state and not the victim
it's therefore disinterested so not in
theory motivated by emotion
and also lacking the sadism of sweet
revenge
it's also proportionate again in theory
you know an eye for an eye sounds brutal
but it's an eye for an eye
and no more than an eye and that could
be considered humane compared to say
revenge killing someone's family for an
eye and it's also consistent
so different offenders are supposed to
get the same punishment for the same
crime i mean unless you're rich in which
case
don't you even worry your little head
about it just pay some gold it's fine
girl these contacts like
[Music]
so there are supposed to be these
differences between revenge and
retributive justice which is why it's so
inappropriate for law enforcement to
identify with the outlaw punisher
modern criminal sentencing accepts
retribution as a goal
while rejecting revenge as lawless
however
i feel that retribute of justice
is still spiritually akin to revenge
it scratches the same emotional itch
it's basically
revenge by proxy if revenge is wild's
justice
then retributive justice is domesticated
revenge
in both cases there's a drive to restore
the moral order of things
to balance out the karma by harming the
person who caused harm
sometimes in a poetic justice kind of
way
like in the code of hammurabi there's
this symbolic retaliation
of punishing the body part that you
offended with
cutting off the hand that struck the
father cutting off the breasts of the
wet nurse who switched the babies
cutting out the tongue that renounced
its parents there's a kind of aesthetic
dimension to this
an appreciation for this symmetry of
punishment and crime
for a modern example here's a poetic
justice post from our slash instant
karma
mugshots.com puts people's mug shots
online and then demands payment to take
them down
the site's founders were just arrested
for extortion here are their mugshots
there's something
metaphysically pleasant about poetic
justice
this sense of beautiful cosmic harmony
and my guess is that this way of
thinking originates in some primeval
human instinct that's difficult to get
rid of
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't
question it the logic of retribution has
been questioned for thousands of years
by philosophers reformists
messiahs you know fancy people who think
they're too good to enjoy
violence one school of anti-retribution
thought we could call
the love and forgiveness school and the
main love and forgiveness guy
is a preachy lib you may have heard of
called jesus of nazareth
back in bible times the hebrews had laws
of retributive justice that were similar
to the code of hammurabi
like in the book of exodus god gives a
bunch of laws to moses
including some relaunches of hammurabi
classics
viewers at home may now open up your
bibles to exodus 21-22
if people are fighting and hit a
pregnant woman and she gives birth
prematurely but there is no serious
injury the offender must be fined
whatever the woman's husband demands in
the court allows
but if there is serious injury you are
to take life for life
eye for eye tooth for tooth hand for
hand
foot for foot burn for burn wound for
wound
bruise for bruise head pots for head
pads
welcome the cowgirl bible study neo
devotional gay sound zulu i feel very
spiritually aroused right now
my third eye chakra dripping macaroni in
a pot
i need jesus i'm so sorry so the law of
moses is pretty based and uncooked
it's basically an eye for an eye don't
be a homo
you know basic common sense but then
jesus comes along and he's
riding his high horse of love and
forgiveness in matthew 26
52 a disciple tries to defend jesus from
being arrested after judas betrays him
but jesus says put your sword back in
his place spartacus
all who draw the sword will die by the
sword now some people read that as
saying that violence begets violence and
should be renounced
even to the point where you shouldn't
defend yourself which is peak radical
centrism
denying the right of marginalized people
to defend themselves
rethink this it gets worse in the sermon
on the mount
jesus says love your enemies and pray
for those who persecute you
love your enemies but i don't want to
love my enemies
no loving smashing but maybe
jesus wasn't as literal minded as that
you know religion is a very subjective
thing and
i have my own bible interpretations and
my personal view is that a lot of what
jesus
says is actually sarcasm
like consider matthew 5 38 why is no one
talking about matthew 5 38 jesus says
you've heard that it was said an eye for
an eye and a tooth for a tooth but i say
to you
do not resist an evildoer but if anyone
strikes you in the right cheek
turn the other also think of the drama
of what he's asking you to do here
someone strikes you across the face
and you go ugh
this is not pacifism this is passive
aggression
some sort of primeval hebrew shade this
is the christianity of
okay well i'll pray for you
but if you do take jesus at face value
then i would argue that his endorsement
of love and forgiveness as a response to
wrongdoing
is not justice at all it's an
alternative to justice
in the absence of justice forgiveness
is an emotional unburdening of the
resentment and anger
the victims of injustice experience and
religion often provides this release
instructing people not to worry too much
about serving earthly justice
because justice is really god's business
and he'll take care of that when the day
of judgment comes
it's a little bit like in hinduism and
buddhism there's the idea of
karma which is like a cosmic law of
moral cause and effect
that exists independently of any god or
human institution
you reap what you sow basically so maybe
don't worry about injustice
too much because karma will take care of
it this kind of thinking is sometimes
called
the just world fallacy the cognitive
bias that sees the world as inherently
fair and good
everything happens for a reason if
something really horrible happens
like a child is murdered people say
there's a special place in god's kingdom
for little angels taken up so soon and
then they'll fantasize about the killer
going to hell and being
anally demolished by fire demons or
whatever people reassure
themselves like this because it relieves
the stress
of enduring unresolved injustice in the
bible the book of job
deals with the problem of injustice why
do bad things happen to good people
and the answer is just don't worry about
it it's it's part of god's plan
it'll all work out in the end it's fine
everything's fine the alternative
is being burdened with the awareness
that the world is just kind of
very not good in which case you might
start getting ideas in your head about
i don't know maybe changing some things
i guess i should disclaimer that hashtag
not all religion and obviously many
political activists have been influenced
by faith
but let's put a pin in that for now 3.
utilitarianism so there's also a secular
tradition of
anti-retribution thinking which tries to
define
justice as something other than
retaliation
utilitarian reformists have argued that
the goal of criminal justice
should be to improve society rather than
punishment for punishment's sake
utilitarianism is the moral theory which
says that the right thing to do
is whatever causes the highest ratio of
human happiness to human suffering
so the utilitarian approach to
punishment looks forward
at preventing future crimes where
retribution looks backward at punishing
past
crimes revenge by proxy some utilitarian
punishment goals might be deterrence
punishing criminals as an incentive for
others not to offend
or incapacitation of criminals in
prisons
or rehabilitation of criminals trying to
educate or discipline them so that they
can re-enter society
a lot of people consider these
utilitarian goals to be more rational
and scientific than retribution
which is very based in emotions also the
utilitarian idea of justice makes sense
even if you don't believe in free will
because retribution really only makes
sense if you believe that people freely
choose their actions
and are therefore culpable for their
behavior and can be deserving
of punishment because punishing someone
for something they didn't meaningfully
choose
seems well the greek historian herodotus
tells a story about the persian king's
xerxes ordering the sea
to be whipped with 300 lashes after a
storm destroyed his bridge
which seems irrational right to punish a
force of nature
leave my beautiful wet wife alone it's
debatable how free humans are
like we're at least partially products
of our genetics
our environment our upbringing our
hogwarts house
the placement of venus in our natal
chart dry oilier combination
and modern criminal sentencing tries to
take all of that into consideration like
you might get a lighter sentence if you
argue that
you know your mother never took you to
disneyland it was a crime of
passion through no fault of my own i was
high on bath salts at the time of the
tax evasion your honor
a lot of the language around punishment
in our legal system is utilitarian like
prisons are called correctional
facilities and not
retribution cages but correctional
facilities is a euphemism
because the fact is these facilities are
not doing very much correcting
i'm sorry in the united states
two-thirds of released prisoners are
re-arrested within three years
and 76 are re-arrested within five years
and just think about the way we talk
about incarceration
like if someone really evil gets a long
sentence we say
good i hope he rots in prison like when
was the last time you heard about a
criminal sentencing and someone said
good the proven efficacy of our
correctional facilities will
rehabilitate this man and release him a
contributing member of his community so
even the institutions we have that are
supposed to serve a correctional or
rehabilitative function
are still obviously satisfying our urge
to punish
i think the problem with utilitarianism
is that while it's very
rational it's often offensive to human
emotions
and you can say facts don't care about
your feelings we shouldn't be basing our
legal system on whatever sadistic
caprice passes through your mind
and i agree with you but the fact
remains if someone hurts your child
you don't want to rehabilitate him you
want to set him on fire
and this disconnect between the legal
system and human emotion
affects law enforcement too a youtuber
called jose
has a video called why some cops think
they're the punisher
which argues that some cops and soldiers
admire the punisher
because they relate to his military
background while fantasizing
about the moral simplicity of his
vigilantism
jose quotes from interviews with
military punisher fans who say things
like
castle doesn't see shades of grey which
unfortunately the american justice
system is littered with and which tends
to slow down and sometimes
even hinder victims of crime from
getting the justice they deserve
frank castle is the ultimate definition
of occam's razor for the military
don't worry about uniforms inspections
or restrictive rules of engagement
find the bad guys kill the bad guys
protect the innocent
any true warrior that's the dream so
these cops and soldiers feel cramped
by rules of engagement and use of force
restrictions
that are keeping them from serving swift
and brutal justice
you know law enforcement would be a lot
easier
if it weren't for all these pesky laws
there's a childish simplicity and
dualism to this moral worldview find the
bad guys
kill the bad guys again it reminds me of
the nra rhetoric about how you need a
good guy with a gun
to stop a bad guy with a gun they sound
like eight-year-old boys playing cops
and robbers
good guys and bad guys
that's my impression of an
eight-year-old boy and to be fair i
totally understand the appeal of moral
simplicity
people love justice served and instant
karma videos for a reason
we take satisfaction in swift decisive
elegant retribution but the procedures
of law enforcement and criminal justice
don't allow for that there's all these
tedious roadblocks
right to an attorney right to remain
silent right to a fair trial
presumption of innocence a lot of police
wish they could simplify things by being
judge jury and executioner but the
function of police is supposed to be
limited to making arrests and initiating
criminal investigations
they're not supposed to be walking
avatars of karma
dispensing free-form retribution in the
streets at will
justice served now with 20 more police
brutality but a lot of people defend
the police when they behave like this
because the thin wristed civilians
are just as emotionally frustrated by
due process as the cops
well did i just say all lives are
bastards i'm double cancelled well look
all lives are bastards but only some
bastards are armed by the state and
licensed to go bastarding around
town the rest of us have to be bastards
on our off time i also think there's a
secular
version of the just world fallacy going
on here people like to think that if the
police kill somebody
it must be because that person did
something wrong karma at work
just as served victim blaming is an
expression of the just world fallacy
you get what you deserve so if something
bad happens to you
you must have been asking for it and
obviously racism is a huge part of this
you know there's
structural white supremacy that occupies
black neighborhoods with police instead
of investing in communities and people
are prejudiced and more likely to think
of black people as criminal thugs and
therefore deserving of police violence
so we get this no angel discourse that
comes up every time a black person is
murdered by the police
where they bring up the victim's
criminal record or a picture of them
looking like a scary thug as if that
proves they deserved to die
the problem with this of course is that
no one
is an angel there are no angels walking
this earth
we're all flawed we've all made mistakes
we've all done bad things that doesn't
mean we deserve to die of violent death
and then there's people like brianna
taylor and elijah mclean who as far as
we know were about as close to angels as
humans come
but that didn't protect them so that is
beside the point because black people in
america should not literally have to
have white feather wings and glowing
halos to deserve not to be murdered by
the police
in fact people of all races have the
absolute right to be low-life
drug-addicted petty criminals who
contribute absolutely nothing to society
and yet still
not be executed by the cops because
that's what it's supposed to mean
to live in a free country so things need
to change the punisher police have got
to go
and a lot of the rest of our justice
system with them we need to imagine a
whole new approach to justice
and to be honest that might take more
than one youtube video
i know at the beginning i said i was
going to explain what justice is but
um i lied
i'm sorry that i can't fix america i'm
just a lonely cat
i guess the only solution is revolution
and by revolution i do mean vote
democrat and then bully the democrats
into actually doing something
and if they don't listen
[Music]
hang on let me get this
motion mushy hey how are you chase
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
out
oh
[Music]
you